i might be stupid here i might know but
there's not a remix like an official
like remix because you know i saw
fireboy put out the remix of ed sheeran
and then
we had the essence remix like i feel
like it's only natural i know you
dropped a new single but i know that
i'm sure a lot of people have wanted to
hop on this record
yeah i mean
yeah like
lots of people wanted to do love on 20
remixes
but like i actually turned down a lot of
them because i mean i can't remix one
song with the whole industry
i mean like that would be nice but like
yeah i just felt like
in terms of remixing and
all that stuff for me it's it's more of
a vibe thing it's not like always a
commercial movie like not go chase the
big name yeah like
the big names are great and everything
and i'm i'm very open to working with
the big names and everyone else as long
as there is a vibe
you know it'll make no sense to to make
music or do something with someone who
has
you know let's say a billion streams if
in reality so you turned down justin
bieber for the remix i never said that
but like just say like if if if we meet
like face to face and we have a sit down
like you and i are having right now and
there's no connection why are we gonna
do the rematch nothing matters anymore
because like you know even if even if
it's one stream you have and there's a
connection
you you know two artists could make a
song that could change the whole world